everyone's heard of bird box but how
deep have you really dug into where
we've gone and gathered up some moments
in the movie that you may have missed so
take off that blindfold here's a look at
the small details you missed in bird box
the first flashback in the film opens a
Mallory's apartment where her sister
Jessica brings her groceries to restock
a fridge they also discussed the
painting Mallory is working on the
artwork is filled with people standing
next to each other in the darkness close
but not interacting before we even get
to know her it's a telling clue -
Mallory's mind sets the painting
reflects Mallory's fears that she won't
be able to form a loving attachment with
a run born child foreshadowing her later
struggles with a nameless boy and girl
it also suggests a bigger and pending
problem of being isolated from
civilization in a world of ravaged by
monsters I see a whole bunch of people
sitting together but they all feel
incredibly lonely loneliness is just
incidental joy about people's inability
to connect right before Gary reveals
himself as a servant of the creatures he
lays out a series of drawings showing
what seems to be his personal take on
what the monsters look like several of
the drawings of distinct features
hinting towards specific supernatural
designs including one of the most famous
cosmic horrors in the history of
literature Cthulhu the cephalopod head
of one of the monsters is subtly
threatening and immediately
distinguishable while the monsters are
probably not literally cohorts of
Cthulhu the drawing seems to be a
shout-out to one of the founders of
modern horror HP Lovecraft the writer
was a master a crafting cosmic
nightmares often leaning largely on the
fear of the unknown bird Fox takes
inspiration from a lot of horror stories
that came before it but the idea of a
monster so other world leaders
impossible to show on screen owes a
major debt to Lovecraft likely inspiring
this nod to one of the author's most
infamous creations when Mallory first
reaches the house Society is in the
middle of falling apart as a phone in
cable networks began to fail
1cor manages to get through leading to a
heart-wrenching scene between two
despairing parents and their child who
clearly sees one of the monsters while
on the phone after rushing out the door
without a thought for her own safety the
couple isn't seen again in the movie or
at least are not seen alive when the
group heads out in the car with
blacked-out windows to
supplies they run over several speed
bumps in the road one of which turns out
to be the couple's bodies lying in the
street not so far from the house while
their faces are hard to recognize their
clothes are the same providing some
closure for their gruesome fate justice
people the scene in Mallory's apartment
is actually a gold mine for little
teasers of the apocalypse to come
another painting next to the larger
piece she's working on sports a number
of elements to eerily foretell the
events that are about to unfold a deer
can be seen being hunted by a wolf while
a ghoulish form hovers over them add
that to the appearance of a bird above
it all and the whole piece seems to
scream out with some kind of prophetic
foreknowledge Maori can't tell the
future but it's interesting to note that
this specific scenario seems to be on
her mind one way or another her
subconscious aura coming Sandra Bullock
carries bird box on her shoulders but
she's helped by some stellar supporting
actors including John Malkovich who
plays the oppressive Douglass he wants
to survive at any cost
while Douglass's character was made up
for the movie adaptation of the original
book that didn't make him expendable in
fact he ends up playing a pretty crucial
role in saving Mallory and the
children's lives even though he
ultimately becomes a hero no one really
likes Douglas but you also give him
credit
the man is never wrong everything he
says ends up happening he's against his
wife leaving the house and she dies he
resists allowing Olympia in and she ends
up letting in Gary he doesn't trust Gary
and the Carrie ends up killing people
even his frivolous lawsuit against his
neighbor who wanted to build a glass
house ends up being the right call his
property why do you care what he bones
because I have to look at it Douglas may
have come off as annoying but you have
to admit that he's right imagine
covering up that many windows of
newspapers without getting a glimpse of
the monsters fat chance I think it's a
huge mistake well you would Douglas you
think everything is a huge mistake
much of Bert Boggs revolves around
Mallory and her kids taking a desperate
trip down river in a rowboat the trip
takes over two days and comes with an
incredible number of challenges making
the feat even more impressive as a fact
that the character is fairly new to
rowing only getting better as she goes
along Bullock does a great job showing
this evolution of scale
as we see her initially flailing
whipping the oars around and trying to
get her sea legs as she launches the
boats by the end however she's seen
rubbing with focus and determination
like an old pro it turns out that this
wasn't just acting Bullock actually had
no experience rowing when she stepped
into the boat purposefully leading on
her lack of know how to make her
performance more realistic the river
scenes were filmed in order so her
rubbing would naturally improve as a
movie progressed you can almost see it
as a metaphor for parenting he kind of
just fake it till you make it
we're going on the trip now it's going
to be rough Mallory's paintings really
are the gift that just keeps on giving
one extra off-the-wall Easter Egg comes
in the form of catfish host Nev Schulman
and his wife Laura who inexplicably
appear in one of Mallory's pieces of art
shortly after the movie came out
Schulman shared a post on Instagram that
highlighted the similarities between the
artwork and his real life he wrote bird
box were scary you know but the
creepiest part is how much the couple in
sandra bullock's painting looks like me
and Laura the resemblance is indeed
remarkable and it didn't take long to
find out why
turns out the resemblance is entirely
intentional in a follow-up post Sherman
admitted he knew more than he was
letting on writing okay okay we actually
know the artist who did the paintings
for Byrd box and pose for her it's a
playful touch from artist Lily Morris
putting a bit of a fun spin on a more
serious film maybe Mallory's just a big
catfish fan news dum-dum-dum-dum check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]